hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we are looking at Easter eggs once
again in fortnight Battle Royale but
this time we are keeping it confined to
season two which ran from December the
14th 2017 to February the 20th 2018 so
if you're ready for this here are
another 15 Easter eggs and cultural
references found in fortnight Battle
Royale the season began with the
introduction of a new battle path which
saw emotes and characters added to the
battlefield many of which were not to
music in TV the first dance to be
unlocked in the battle pass was the ride
the pony emote which of course is a
reference to the bloody annoying song
which took over the world back in 2012
oppan kangnam star bloody Gangnam style
another dance emote which made it into
everyone's lives was the floss made
famous by the back cut kid in 2016 he
blew up overnight and even appeared on
Saturday Night Live with Katy Perry come
on you can be honest now have you ever
tried to floss how much of a [ __ ]
did you look nineties references pop up
regularly in Battle Royale
and this one brings back the days of The
Fresh Prince of bel-air I'm sure you
remember the brilliance of Carlton and
his love of Tom Jones and his classic
track it's not unusual after his
appearance on Dancing with the Stars the
Calton dance became mainstream again and
became part of battle royale known as
the fresh emote again another nod to the
Fresh Prince TV show season 2 also
brought in a huge update to the map with
new areas of interest such as the giant
llama and in the latter updates a
hulking great crab and a fox - but just
west of Aniki acres was a new mind to
discover which is in the shape of an
umbrella the umbrella became synonymous
with good players during the early days
of fortnight Battle Royale this was
because it could only be used by players
who had won in the past
additionally to functioning football
fields were added and an update to the
wooden chair structure found north of
blush Factory other updates included
extra posters found around the gaming
world all referencing previous Epic
Games titles these are found in multiple
areas around the map they are very
pixelated but if you know what you're
looking for it's easy to want
cover we've already looked at the Unreal
Tournament pictures back in season 1 but
now jazz jackrabbit can be found - jazz
jackrabbit was created back in 1994 in
which jazz had to rescue a princess
called Eva Elam I know it sounds
terrible in 2018 but at the time it was
quite impressive next we have Shadow
Complex this one is from 2009 and first
appeared on Xbox Live Arcade and was a
2.5 d scrolling platformer in Shadow
Complex you attempt to save your
kidnapped girlfriend but you can finish
the game in 30 seconds if you choose to
turn around and walk away from your
girlfriend take that as a lesson for
life here's one which took me a while to
get the Transformers looking poster is
from the game one must fall 20 97 made
back in 1994 this was a very
stereotypical fighting game but the
combatants were robotic Lee assisted
cultural references began dropping into
battle royale like they were going out
to fashion during season two one of
which was the electro shuffle which was
directly taken from this young lady the
electro dance movement has been growing
considerably in the last 10 years first
scene over in France back in 2007 I have
a question
can anybody above the age of 25 do this
without looking like they're having a
seizure it's not possible memes also
started making appearances in fortnight
during season two with the most
impressive being the pure salt emote to
be salty is supposedly what happens when
someone becomes pissed-off angry or just
generally bitter with a video game this
was taken to the next level by adding
this fellow spreading salt onto his meat
in a dramatic way by the way the first
time I saw the word meme I thought it
was pronounced to me me I'm so [ __ ] on
with the show
gliders became big business during
season two with the half-shell design
hitting the marketplace I'm sure you get
the reference already but just in case
this is a nod to the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles and their nickname heroes
in a half-shell
the art style closely resembles a 2013
interation of the quartet made by
Nickelodeon
okay who's next twitch stream has begun
to take over the world during season two
of battle royale and epic games began to
honor them in their own little Easter
eggs the first arrival for
record-breaking streamer ninja and a
pickaxe made especially for him the
plunger was released after ninja tweeted
this I literally am trying to throw
money at the game dude I would buy a
toilet plunger a xanax just give us new
shoots so what did epic do take a
plunger and connect a ninja sword to it
alright that's that's pretty epic I
quite like okay so that's it so that's
everything I found during season two of
battle royale did I miss any please let
me know your thoughts and if you missed
our previous episode about Easter eggs
in season one I'll link it now in our
next episode we'll be breaking down
everything season three has to offer I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade as always
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]